Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you, Ruffians!
It's the 83rd FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for having us as a part of your morning.
Wow, we feel really lucky.
Especially so today.
BAU BAU!
Wow, for any Ruffians joining us for the very first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, I don't know if that's supposed to be the part where you get excited about.
BAU BAU.
I'm happy to see you excited though.
Yeah!
It's good to be excited in the morning.
There's another amazing day waiting for us, Ruffians!
So let's do our best today too.
FUWAMOCO-chan!
What's been going on for FUWAMOCO?
What do you have this FUWAMOCO Morning?
Maybe this isn't as exciting.
Huh?
Exciting?
Not exciting?
Which one is it?
There's been another Pero Sighting.
Well!
Where's Pero this time, huh?
Let's see!
De-den!
Oh!
This is cute!
But... Pero...
You say he's making friends, but... Are you sure?
Are you supervising them?
I don't know what... If you don't, things could get very ugly very quick.
But, you know, your life is busy too.
You don't have all day to watch over them and see that nothing weird happens.
I have an idea.
Well...
Some very cute plushies there.
Why don't you make sure to add two RUFFIAN plushies to your household as well?
That way, they can help guard over and monitor the situation for you.
Good idea!
Right?
You know, Ruffians, you can still add more RUFFIAN plushies to your army right now, so don't forget!
Don't forget!
We can't forget.
We can't forget!
If you want an army, now is the chance!
Ruffian army.
Ima shika nai!
You know, I really like how they're peeking around the door at you.
Even Pero?
It's cute.
Even Pero maybe.
Well, I hope everything works out and you know, that you have fun with the company there too.
BAU BAU!
Yeah.
Pero meets Takodachi.
I know.
Hopefully everything will be okay.
It'll be a nice meeting, huh?
Yeah.
For sure!
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
In just a few weeks, hololive Expo 2024 and FIFTH FES capture the moment will be happening in Tokyo at Makuhari Messe!
BAU BAU!
We're very excited.
There's even more exciting news coming out right now.
You might know, but Expo is like a big party, right?
Big party, yeah.
What's a party without some food and drinks?
BAU BAU!
Dance food!
And also, this year's theme, hololive Foods and Beverages, were just announced.
And among that lineup is...
I'm FUWAMOCO Drink!
BAU BAU!
I'm FUWAMOCO Drink, what do you think, Ruffians?
To explain a little bit about it, it's a white soda based drink featuring us!
FUWAMOCO!
Mio-senpai did a taste test of...
FUWAMOCO Milk!
It's a white soda ruffian.
White soda!
Okay, but you know Mio-senpai also came up with a cat copy for it.
And it was something like, you might drown in their fluffy and fuzzy cream.
It's so busy that you'll BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I'm glad that Mio-senpai enjoyed it.
You know, if you get it at Expo as well!
It'll also come with a special themed coaster and printed signature from our snow!
If you get tasty, we love it!
If you wanna choose, our special FUWAMOCO drink!
BAU BAU!
I don't know, I think this sounds a little bit better than the Fuwa Water.
Why?
It's a white soda, Ruffians.
Use your brain.
Like a whipped cream on top.
And the sprinkles, too.
Right!
It's not complete without the sprinkles.
And the coaster, too!
I'm excited.
Nomitai deshita!
Liquid Pero-Pero's not included.
No.
It's the FUWAMOCO drink, not the Pero drink.
That would be terrifying.
I did not think about that.
Ruffians, earlier this morning, FUWAMOCO, we were up early because we had a collab with Choco-senpai!
Choco-senbin, Choco-sen.
She took our measurements and I...
Asked us some very personal questions.
It's okay though.
It's okay.
You know it.
Because it's Toko-sen.
You know she'll help us with any of our issues.
As a trustworthy class nurse she is, you know.
She even said she would rub my tummy and make it feel better when it hurts.
That's nice.
Yeah.
We talked about a bunch of things and we laughed a lot!
And had a bunch of fun too!
And Moco-chan, you even got to touch a horn, right?
Yeah, I did!
It felt nice, sorta.
Sorta soft.
Sorta hard.
But, Ruffians... Only afterwards did I realize...
Do you know what we forgot?
Wow.
We should have asked Choco-san about why Moco-chan sneezes so much.
It would have been a good chance, huh?
Right?
We could have got that checked out.
It was finally the chance to get checked out by a professional we totally forgot!
Ruffians.
Why?
Why didn't you remind us, huh?
Huh, Ruffians?
I guess we're all just having too much fun.
Yeah.
Probably!
BAU BAU, yeah.
Too much fun, right?
Right!
You have work!
I guess that's a good excuse.
I guess, you know, oh well.
We'll just have to chat more with Tsukose sometime soon.
That's only twice.
Yup, and then you know, we can look forward to her professional opinion then.
Right.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, you missed something.
A collab with Tsukose, maybe?
Check it out over on Soko-san's channel!
Okay!
BAU BAU!
So.
Ruffians.
I wonder, do you have this sometimes?
You know, when you're trying to go to sleep and you're sort of starting to drift off.
You know, some crazy thoughts come to your head, sort of knocking you out of that sleepy state.
Do you have that?
No.
No?
Every time, yeah.
I hope it's not every time.
Well, you know, the other day, the thought came to me.
Does Pero have anyone special in his life?
You know, is there, in fact, a so-called girly old friend of his?
This is it!
You know, he sure does seem to focus on cute girls sometimes.
But truth be told, he's just our pet.
So, we don't really know those details about his life.
You know, we don't want to know.
No.
You know, why would we ask about stuff like that?
It's not important.
No, no.
I mean, does he have any family members?
If he had a sister, do you think she'd look like this, Ruffians?
Would she be Pero Tina?
Lots of questions, huh?
I don't know.
Maybe this is a bit of a disturbing thought.
You see, you know, the ones that get you at that sleepy state are a bit strange, huh?
Yeah.
I don't know!
Um, Moco-chan.
It's kind of rude to think about these things, no?
I can't control my sleep thoughts, okay?
It just happens.
It just came to me, you know, and I couldn't help but think about it.
What do you think, Ruffians?
I'm not being rude!
I don't know.
If there is a Perroccino, there could be a Perroccino, right?
Don't misunderstand, okay, Ruffians?
You have nightmares from this one?
Yeah, well...
You'd rather not think about it.
I don't know if there is, in fact, a Perroccino.
Do we want that?
I don't know.
My gut says no.
I guess mine does too, huh?
BAU BAU!
It's too personal.
You know what, Ruffians?
Just forget about this.
Yeah.
If we think about it for too long, it just gets upsetting, so... I think they agree.
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU.
You don't wanna... I don't wanna go by the Perroccino.
My Perroccino.
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Goodbye.
Do we have anything happier, Moco-chan?
Yeah!
We do!
That's good.
I need something happier.
Ruffians!
You remember this, right?
The Legendary Game Series.
Toho!
Right?
Because recently we played a game from, well, the Legendary Bullet Hell series here and there.
And Moco-chan was surprisingly good at it, right?
Right!
You know.
Yeah.
I even impressed myself a bit.
You know, I really didn't think I'd get as far as I did, huh?
Yeah, you were surprised!
Right!
Surprisingly, yes.
Thank you.
You know, the other day, Marine Senchou-senpai, she was playing Touhou Kanjuuden.
The Legacy of the Lunatic Kingdom.
And apparently, this is one of the most difficult Touhou games.
And well, Senchou-senpai, she was still playing online.
And not easy!
Yeah!
Even though it's so tough.
And you know she was doing so well, but it got stuck.
But then, you know, she would keep on trying until she cleared the area and continued.
Right?
Right, right!
It was so amazing!
I couldn't help but, you know, clap and be so noisy even though it's super early in the morning, right?
Right!
I don't know, we're always so amazed watching her play and, you know, she asked us to try to play Conjugate as well!
What do you think, Ruffians?
Should we maybe practice some other, maybe easier titles before taking on Kanji Den?
Should we have to sit with Senpai's challenge?
Yeah.
Give it a go!
Try it!
It does sound like fun, that is true.
It is, but you know what?
Maybe get some coaching!
Why?
I really do enjoy playing Touhou, you know?
I would like to get good at it too, like Senchou-senpai!
She was saying, oh you really think I'm good, huh?
Of course!
It's a little spooky sometimes, right, Senchou-senpai?
She's just so good at it!
I don't know.
Moco-chan, do your best, okay?
BAU BAU!
If you haven't tried it before, Ruffians, go check it out on Steam, okay?
Well, in other news, actually, today we received a FUWAMOCO Scoop from a Ruffian!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Vistaia, for the impeccable journalism!
Well, Ruffians, it seems like Hayada-senpai and Biboo tried their hands at the Keep Talking, No One Explodes game the other day.
Right.
It's always really fun and intense to remember when we played it, right Moco-chan?
I definitely remember that!
Right?
We had so much fun diffusing the balls together and... We did so fast and coordinated.
Yes.
Yeah.
Wow!
It seems like when Biboo was trying to communicate some of the symbols to Kaede-senpai, I don't know if you can see it there, but there's kind of maybe a letter?
A letter?
A symbol?
That reminded Biboo of something.
Biboo, well, she started to imitate Moco-chan's accent.
She was like, It's Mococo!
Moco-chan.
What do you think of this?
I don't know what she means.
What do people mean by this?
No.
Ruffians!
If you're not familiar... I mean, it's been seven months or so, but if you're not familiar!
My name is Mococo.
M-O-C-O-C-O.
Yep.
That's how it's spelled.
It's no E. No E. Yeah.
So, did Kaila-senpai understand what Biboo meant by that?
Biboo just being silly.
Making Kaila-senpai confused.
That won't make sense.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't think her clue makes too much sense, so... Yeah.
I don't think Kaila-senpai would've got it, but... She did.
She understood.
What?
Immediately!
Understood completely!
I guess I'm glad that I could help.
I'm glad you like it, for whatever reason.
BAU BAU!
I'm glad for you!
You know, as long as Biboo's smiling, Haruna-senpai's smiling, and Ruffians... You're smiling!
Then we're good.
Yeah, but I don't know, maybe it's been a little rough recently.
You know, we're getting to the end of the month.
Maybe the weather's not as good, you know?
Wow, Moco-chan!
Do you have something that maybe you could share with us today?
Do you want that?
The weather's a lot better?
Oh, that's good then!
You don't need it then!
The weather is good!
Doggie of the Day, Doggie of the Day.
I think the Doggie of the Day today is more cute, maybe.
The weather is good, the weather is okay.
Yeah, you have more than enough energy and support than mine.
Wait, please!
Please, Mococo!
Well then!
Ruffians!
It's today!
Today again!
It's that day of the week!
It's the day of the week for our Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me.
Mococo!
Ruffians!
Good morning!
Are you still sleepy there?
Uh...
I can still see the sleep in your eyes a bit, huh?
Has it been a bit rough recently?
Have you been working especially hard?
I don't know.
It sure looks that way to me.
Don't worry!
You're doing amazing!
Here's a head pat.
For all the good work!
Nare nare nare nare!
I know, I know.
With the lack of sleep and the worries of everything on your shoulders, it can be a bit tough.
Sometimes you can't help but feel overwhelmed and maybe even a bit teary sometimes.
But it's okay!
Because you know what?
I'm here for you.
Fuwawa is here for you.
We know you're doing your best.
Just keep on going, and eventually, you'll be so much stronger from all of it.
You know, it may be rough right now, but it's not always gonna be that way.
No matter what it feels like.
Everything will work out!
I know it!
GANBATTE DE!
BAU BAU!
It'll be good.
You can do it, Ruffians!
It'll be good, okay!
BAU BAU, it will work out.
Well then!
Today, our Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
Aspen!
I don't know, that looks like a puppy who's about to cry really hard.
Those ears!
Right, look at those silly ears!
The paws, too.
He looks so happy!
Just a happy puppy.
Aspen is only three months old and apparently it's very difficult to take this picture of him because he's just go go go going everywhere.
He's so fine!
That's a puppy for you.
That's a puppy, yeah.
How do you think Aspen BAU BAUs?
Just like that.
I can see his little, his big feet moving around.
Like what?
Like that.
Well, you know, Aspen is an absolutely adorable puppy!
I think he's excited a hundred hours a day!
Probably!
But if you're not careful, that puppy dog tail might just wag on off.
You have to make sure you keep an eye on him, okay?
He wants to watch over her.
It might be a little hard, though.
I think, for now though, he's definitely the one that's taking you on walks so hard.
BAU BAU!
Asuka looks so fluffy too!
Very fuzzy.
Fuzzy ears.
So cute!
BAU BAU!
Well done!
Next we have... Today I went on a walk.
Today's walk is... DE-DEN!
A walk under the SAKURAN with pondering together with us!
So nice!
BAU BAU!
We're so happy to be able to go for a walk together with you!
Ohanami!
We have Ohanami so much!
Our first Hanami together too!
It's beautiful!
We're so happy that you're able to get out and enjoy all the blossoms, the colors, and the sun!
And for the question of the day, we have De-den!
Good morning, FUWAMOCO!
Good morning!
It tends to be a lot of limited time only food in Japan.
Yeah.
It's a limited item that you've had once, but no matter how much you tried, you could never find it again.
That's a sad story there.
But FUWAMOCO!
I make sure that never happens.
Because I'm so weak to limited time items.
It's really bad.
I've never had this flavor before.
So, you know, if it's limited time, then that's my time to enjoy it lots and lots.
You know, it's hard because they're always so, like, cool and delicious looking, and I feel like I need to get it now, otherwise, you know, I'll never get another chance.
Right?
Like, it's fate.
Our paths crossed in this supermarket.
Right?
But, uh...
I can't think of anything, but...
Well, there was, however, a really yummy grape-flavored black iced tea that the supermarket would always sell with a claim of limited time.
Yeah, it was just a limited time only item.
And you know, it was so good, I was really dreading the day that was one day.
I couldn't get my paws on it again, so I made sure to get it pretty often.
Moco-chan, you- I liked it!
It wasn't very sweet.
No complaints.
Right?
It was really, really refreshing and pretty addictive, too.
But, you know, before we knew it, months and months and months and months went by.
And it was still there.
It's so hot.
Why?
I don't know.
Was it really limited?
Was it just maybe like a week or two that it wasn't there?
Like on a stock level?
When you think about it, everything is limited.
Yeah.
Happy for the morning hot.
But you know, the happy end to the story is, you know, we never had to say goodbye to it, you know?
Just a little bit of a confused FUWAMOCO.
Yeah, but happy.
But I think otherwise, maybe we should do the Matcha Flavor Pondering.
Those are always a nice surprise, right?
They're sort of a surprise.
But original.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your questions, your doggies, your walks, your Pero Sightings.
We're really, really lucky to have you here with us and be a part of FUWAMOCO Morning.
Thank you so much!
We're waiting for more submissions, so please use the hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Well, for our next stream coming up...
We have, uh, uh, we have brunch with Advent over on the Risu Channel.
So make sure you have brunch with us too, okay?
But, uh, after that we also have FUWAMOCO Morning!
You can always depend on it.
And we're picking another gladiator schedule here.
You can see we have a very big Rock n' Roar party coming up on Saturday, Ruffians!
There's been a lot of really, really memorable Rock n' Roar parties.
I'm sure there will also be another one.
We have a big announcement, so we hope, Ruffians, that you'll be able to be there and cheer a bunch for us.
Big, big announcement.
We're looking forward to it!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Once again, we just want you to know how thankful we are to be a part of your morning.
Three times a week?
Right!
There's nothing to sneeze at.
Thank you for letting us into your world.
BAU BAU!
Wow, before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Sangeko!
BAU BAU!
Fima!
ChrisOS!
BAU BAU!
Now all I love is... BAU BAU!
Kiran!
BAU BAU!
Usagi!
Tehojo!
BAU BAU!
Beast!
Mutt!
BAU BAU!
Freeman!
Kaisa!
BAU BAU!
Miyada!
Hongi!
BAU BAU!
To every other ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!